de mystérieux flashcode sur des tombes
de poilus depuis quelques semaines une
cinquantaine comme celui ci ont été
installés dans le cimetière de fleury la
vallée pour honorer le souvenir des
morts pour la france
le principe c'est on flashe avec le
téléphone on a accédé directement au
site
et on a tout le parcours militaire du
soldat donc ici c'est un aviateur ont
pas remis tous les documents retrouvés
on a même la photo de son crash le 20
septembre 1918 pour dresser le portrait
de ces poilus lucie aubert a passé de
nombreuses heures à consulter et
collecter des archives un travail de
recherche colossal pour cette étudiante
passionnée de la grande guerre
c'est un travail qui m'a pris trois ans
entre les archives départementales la
mairie pour divers actes les actes
médicaux
c'est très fastidieux et avec beaucoup
d'attentes à la clé beaucoup d'émotion
un hommage également très émouvant pour
le maire et les descendants de poilu
comme frédéric qui ne connaissait
presque rien de son arrière-grand-père
le seul souvenir que j'avais de mon
arrière grand père c'est cette montre
qu'ils étaient dans la famille et
aujourd'hui grâce au travail de la cible
on en apprend plus sur sur son passage
sur sa vie sur sur sa fin de vie
également c'est une fierté pour toute la
famille effectivement je trouve que
c'est un travail formidable si ces
poilus avait pu savoir qu'un jour une
jeune femme de 25 ans aller leur rendre
un hommage comme ça je peux dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a un cimetière 2.0 qui
fait la fierté du village et de la
région
en plus d'être disponible sur internet
les portraits des poilus de fleury
seront prochainement publiés dans un
livre
la sortie est prévue pour la fin de
l'année